Benjamin dans les grosses poitrines
mais c'est vrai et Cindy non mais c'est
fou cette histoire
j'imagine que c'était Aurore que
Benjamin tu avais invité à dîner que tu
avais dit non que tu avais dragué non je
crois pas non parce que regretté après
de ne pas avoir une aventure avec
Benjamin Castaldi faut réussir il aurait
peut-être fallu que je sais pas je sois
plus conciliante
je suis tombé après
[Musique]
particulier
de Guillaume ça tu l'as dit aussi
parce que Guillaume là c'est amusé à le
dire et que à un moment donné tous ses
copains venaient me voir pour voilà me
répéter ce qui m'avait dit donc je me
suis dit allez hop vous êtes resté
combien de temps Guillaume et toi
ensemble je sais plus on s'est vu
quelquefois plusieurs fois quoi mais
c'était pas pour moi c'était vraiment un
couple quoi
bon vous êtes galoche quand même
j'ai plus l'habitude ça va autant encore
merci
incroyable
une vraie aventure pour de vrai
il y a quelques années deux ont trois
ans
je ne sais pas je ne suis pas d'accord